i actually did go to a bdsm clock once
and it was the most horrific experience
ever i just ended up hanging out by the
buffet the entire night i'm eating
chicken and then i look to my left
somebody's getting
by the chicken what do you think talking
honestly on a first date can do i think
it just gets rid of all like doesn't it
i'm generally quite like honest so this
really works for me actually
who would you want to walk through the
door today the love of my life obviously
i would describe myself as kinky like
i'm pretty wild so they have to be like
cool with that
hey i'm maria okay
oh fantastic there you go cool nice i
love your tattoos by the way thank you
thank you
the burning question
are you a tory
oh
no
yeah no but i'm not labor either okay
there was a brief period of time where i
did go both ways so when i was younger i
was very much liberal and then there was
a time which is where i did kind of go
more into like that right wing kind of
side okay and i just like
how did that happen um
mostly to do like the the pandemic
i think because i used to be the same i
used to be like oh no these guys like
horrible and you know but
when you actually speak to them it's
more just about having
less
like government interference the far
left is just as problematic as the far
right and the far right is just
problematic as the far left i want
everybody to like you know just let's
just all make let's just make love
exactly i am like you know i i love
unity exactly exactly yeah exactly i can
tell about your outfit you've already
started so you know yeah
what about yourself well like that would
be a deal breaker for me if someone was
a tory
i just don't agree with their policies i
don't
agree with inequality
and
i mean my whole philosophy is kind of
like people need to get back to the
roots they need to get back to
yes i'm a hippie they need to get back
to life
small communities people helping each
other out i don't believe in politics
either i think that it's just a way of
like dividing people in a way to like
essentially
create tension between people
i mean and it all kind of like stem from
the monarchy i'm not gonna get into a
rant
yeah i i hate the uk anyway
yeah guys please get your own radio 4
program yeah
how many guys have you slept with
oh okay
actually really
not that many okay how many do you think
i've slept
oh my god i think um i'm going to say a
good
i i did maybe like under 10 under 15.
well yeah close i've slept with like 19
guys 19 guys
well guys and girls because i'm bi okay
yeah yeah yeah could you write that down
or like do you actually have like a
number
i i did at one point want to start
keeping score i did i did i mean but how
many people have you slept with
too many really
why
yeah i know shocked me as well
uh i've actually lost track wow but i do
i know it's shocking for me it's like
universally shocking in my young in my
younger days in my younger days and
there was definitely a point
which is where i was like
yeah i want like huge numbers you know i
want to be like the alpha male guy i
want to have like 100 girls but then i i
don't know i'm like in the past couple
of like years it's kind of like
this is just totally meaningless and
i kind of feel a bit hollow
from like doing all of this and doing
that
and i don't feel too good well i'm quite
spiritual and i believe in like energy
transference and like
when you basically sleep with someone
you're kind of taking on their energy
and if the interaction is very much like
empty and devoid of like feeling or
emotion you will feel empty afterwards
you'll feel like something's been taken
from you i mean like i'm not like i'm
not a spiritual person by the way okay
yeah but i do think that there is like
some like truth to that having sex with
like large volumes of people yeah that
will have a psychological effect on you
like it 100 will
my next question was
are you kinky or vanilla
vanilla i mean it's like pasty skinny
i like i feel like probably
uh
i feel probably in between in between
okay yeah i mean like if i
like i i like a bit of like i guess
rough play um
moss freaked me out
masks yeah anything like moss okay like
gibbs and stuff bdsm i actually did go
to a bdsm clock once
and it was the most horrific experience
ever no one wanted
so no one wanted me and i just ended up
walking around why everyone's having sex
i'm walking around in the tightest
trousers i've ever had in my entire life
yeah was it like pvc yeah yeah and then
i i just ended up hanging out by the
buffet the entire night
and then i looked well yeah you say that
i'm eating chicken and then i look to my
left somebody's getting
by the chicken and i'm just like
i'm like well
yeah no so like now okay so the buffet's
off the table sex is off the table
i think i just went home oh okay she had
a bad experience bad experience
what about yourself are you
yeah like i like to kind of like dip my
toes and all of that i think it's really
exciting and i find it like
a break from like the everyday mundane
life
i think that like kinks or something to
be explored within people i mean like
you know fraud you've heard about like
um everything he said and like how it
works what sigmund fraud
freud
freud oh gosh sigmund
well he was like he would talk about
like our subconscious desires and like
why people are like attracted to certain
things and i think it's interesting like
i like being quite dominant you like
being dominant yeah okay okay like it's
fun it's you know mixes it up a little
bit when you just have vanilla sex
it's just so boring
kings are just a way to explore it
doesn't have to be you can be kinky but
without being like going to a sex club
like you oh yeah
which i think is um
is good yeah yeah yeah just like you
know spice things up a bit you've got to
keep it interesting yeah no of course
you've always got to keep it interesting
how much porn do you watch how much porn
do i watch yeah um i actually don't
watch
that much like
i'm very much um
a do it in person kind of thing like
if i'm feeling hot like horny
i am not really gonna go to sights like
i feel like porn can be quite addictive
so it's best to just like you know self
pleasure and do things that are like
isabrill because
a lot of it is quite like forced do you
watch a lot of porn
a bit
sadly yeah
maybe i don't i don't know as a girl but
i think like as a guy you are introduced
to sex very early on yeah like these
days i had friends that would piss out
me because i didn't know what butt blood
was stuff like that yeah at the age of
like 14 15 and then of course i'm just
like oh no i don't want to seem stupid
i'm going to go research what backplug
is
a lot of guys have said this to me like
they felt like peer pressured into it
almost i think it's all like kind of
like a need to grow up really really
quickly so i think that's where it comes
from but again not very happy with how
much fun i watch oh okay
okay cool this is going to expose me
this is like similar to what we're
talking about but would you be with
someone who has an oni fans
[Music]
[Music]
i don't think so
really okay
i don't think so i kind of like you know
i don't really want other guys like
staring at like my girl or like like
wanking awful like it's like a private
thing for me um
so so would you say that you wouldn't be
open to explore like polyamory or like
no those types of relationships okay
yeah but don't you think that like
people like humans
are like just naturally attracted to
other people and why should they just
have to be with like one person for the
rest of their life like is that
realistic i've known people to go into
polo polyamorous relationships and stuff
and my experience by what i've seen it's
never worked out there's always at least
one person that is just so
so not happy
would you are you and only fans
i do have only fans yes and
there is a liberation in expressing
yourself and
being who you want to be and doing what
you want to do and then it kind of goes
back in with polyamory and like i want
the freedom to be able to express myself
and the freedom to be able to do what i
want if i'm honest i think polyamory is
like the
the easy option
okay i think it's a lot harder to go
okay like i'm attracted to this person
but i care for this person and i don't
want to disappoint this person i want to
show my loyalty to this person it's
about putting
the other person before yourself
will this date end in sex
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no
that's fine that's yeah that's fine no
obviously yeah
i think the only reason i asked that
question was
because
when uh i'm on a date or a guy's on a
date the thing i'm definitely thinking
is like is this date gonna end in sex
it's a horrible thought totally shallow
i hate the fact that i think it but it
is the thought that creeps into my mind
would you like to go on another day
um
[Music]
i think you're an interesting person
but you are not my type sadly and you
seem like a lovely person oh thank you
but unfortunately i don't think that
i would
go on another date with you yeah
that's fine that's fine just sound like
everyone i've ever loved no no i'm
really joking um i would say the uh the
same oh okay but i think you're lovely
oh thank you
he seemed like a nice guy i wasn't like
attracted to him to put it bluntly i
thought she was really sweet actually i
didn't agree with her but i thought she
was really sweet
i think he's the kind of guy that is
like just thinking about like i mean he
even admitted he was like yeah so when
are we gonna have sex like on the day
and fair enough to him this is you know
like about honesty but it's just like
okay so that's really what you're
thinking about so definitely no date two
no
no
for some guys they have to nut
to see if they really like the girl
right so sometimes after sex they might
be like this didn't feel right okay and
like we feel bad because we don't want
to we don't want to make you feel used
yeah okay so you answered about some
guys but what about you